[Music]
brothers brothers brothers see when are
we gonna think of ourselves as more than
this what y'all doing y'all rollin huh
flippin stupid mm-hmm
boxing Maxie Saxon is the stoop oh yeah
I used to flip roll whatever you want to
call it me and my crew we were getting
to activities much like yourself
did you see the problem was we were only
perpetuating the stereotype the system
already assumes about us
hmm you see we need to stop feeding into
the preconceived notions that we are oh
you really work hard to do hey I wish I
could pay you more but you know why are
you uh-huh what do you want oh I don't
know
as you were as you were watch much guy
who y'all see me
ah brothers brothers brothers look at
yourselves pants hanging off your ass
looking like a couple of clowns which
you are okay enjoy the birthday
celebration brother brother
sir everybody in this self-defense class
has already paid to participate if
you're interested you can sign up online
I'm interested good why I came over here
I'm gonna think about it I'm interested
thank you stuff now latest it's gonna
get really intense today no matter what
happens I will be groping your
breasteses mother brother my brother but
I was watching you now you old brothers
need to break the stereotype and stop
being so preaching you know what I'm
preachy hmm come on you preachy man bus
you older than me I'm nine years old I
got Benjamin buttons disease hmm I'm
done I'm done
you